they knocked over the sound equipment
they ran away they
actually defecated on the sound
equipment it was it was carnage yeah
[Music]
hi there i'm sam hewn i'm about to play
last time i
on the kelly clarkson show with many
kills
[Music]
last time i was star struck i would love
to say it was actually kelly clarkson i
mean she's just a fantastic host right
i mean i'm sucking up to her but she was
a very very sweet
um really cool host and hopefully we get
to meet her in person next time
[Music]
last time i had an awkward audition i
have to admit would be a long time ago
because i've been on
outlander now for what feels like most
of my life
a good eight years um but it was
probably it was
probably for game of thrones which i
went in on
i think a number of times i think it's
been reported i was in there seven
times but uh yeah obviously didn't get
the job
[Music]
the last time i laughed so hard i cried
would be
to be honest is my with my co-star
katrina balf when outlander we
she has got the the worst corpse ever
so what happens is is that she'll she'll
start laughing
she'll turn her back and just openly
laugh and then usually leave me to
to remain you know in the scene and
having to just hold it so
um yeah there's been countless countless
occasions where we just lose it but
she's she's so much just so much fun so
i'm very lucky to be with her but
damn she's she's really good at hiding
her laughter
some last time i cried during a movie
or tv show would be
to be honest have you seen the
documentary um
my octopus teacher i know it's an
octopus
it's like a creature and from the sea
but this guy like forges this
relationship with his octopus and it's
like
it's pretty sad so yeah it's i i get i
get
worked up for sea life
uh last time i shot an outlander meme
was probably the last time i
went on social media i tend to love
using those because our fans are
so good they're so engaged they create
all these memes
um so there's a great multitude of
outlander memes to share
so yeah i love them
last time i drank alcohol was probably
on the kelly clarkson show
um i finished my glass of whiskey
i'm afraid
last time i got great advice from an
outlander co-star
um would be to be honest you know
it's my my good friend gray mctavish you
know who's on many kills with me
he's uh he's in outlander of course he
plays my uncle or did until i killed him
but on many kills you know he i'm such a
fun adventure kind of guy like just
doing stuff
he's more sedate and slow but he told me
he said you know you've got to
take things at a slower pace sometimes
to enjoy the scenery and actually he's
right
sometimes it is good to just uh sit back
and enjoy the ride
[Music]
the last time i hugged an animal would
be
adso the cat which is a cat we have on
outlander
and um it is just delightful and i
i actually am thinking about getting my
own cat because i've kind of fallen in
love with him
the other animal i hugged but it was
less of a hug and more of a it was like
a bear hug
it was a sheep while we were trying to
hurt sheep and shear them on men and
kilts
and uh it didn't turn out too well they
don't like hugs
in fact this this one in particular
really didn't enjoy it and uh
all the sheep managed to escape and it
was carnage they knocked over the sound
equipment
they ran away they they actually
defecated on the sound equipment
it was it was carnage yeah so don't
don't go hugging sheep
[Music]
last time i had a paranormal encounter
was on men and killed so this is
the gods on earth truth we went to
castle loud which is the home of the
mckenzies
and the chief of clan mackenzie was
there and he told us
multiple ghost stories but one in
particular what was about the night
watchman who was this
uh gentleman who would have a lantern
and he lived in the guard room and he'd
come up through the
stone staircase the chief clan mackenzie
claims that he hears the night watchman
every night
walking up the steps as we were talking
about him
the door in the room we're in opened and
then slammed shut
as if the night watchman didn't like
what we're talking about
[Music]
last time i was mistaken for another
celebrity
to be honest my first ever american
football game i went to see the chicago
bears
and i was buying i think a large whiskey
because that's
what you do at the football right and uh
some guy thought i was tom brady so i
had to deny that i was tom brady and i
was like
does tom brady drink whiskey surely not
last time i landed an exciting role
well i have two movies about ah there
are out
um right now one is going to be on the
12th of march in america and canada and
it's called sas red notice
and i'm really excited about it because
it's an action
thriller um based on andy mcnabb's
best-selling novels and
yeah it's it's a really cool character
for me and a really great movie and the
other one
is paul newman in a movie called two
olivia i'm
blink and you'll miss me but it's uh
it's a beautiful movie about roald dahl
and patricia neal so catch them both
[Music]
last time i should check right now right
last time i texted an outlander co-star
was uh
last night i texted katrina balf and
i said that um i hope the weather's okay
because it's been snowing here a lot so
she's okay
last time i made something i was super
proud of
well i've been trying to make like all
of us you know during lockdown we all
have been you know making kind of
whatever bread i've been trying to make
sourdough i admit right i'm a bit late
to the game i've already just started
it's been weeks now i've been feeding
this damn starter thing and it's getting
bigger and bigger and yet still i don't
know
what's going on and it's like it's
taking out my life every
every night after work i come home and i
feed this thing and i just
i just want it to be over the last time
i ever play this game is on the kelly
clarkson show
thank you want more fun stuff
i thought so check out these videos
floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure